car tester Reinhold Dyson / ass why wait
to go electric when you can do it now
we'll have to wait till 2020 for the VW
ID now a concept car and even longer for
the buzz Electric VW Bus but we
generally don't need 400 kilometers
range maybe less will do nicely so today
we'll be testing the plug-in hybrid the
VW Passat GTE the Passat GTE has two
power plants a 1.4 liter gasoline engine
and an electric motor for a total system
capacity of 160 kilowatts and a maximum
torque of 400 Newton meters for driving
modes make the Passat energy-efficient
sporty or in between I know it explains
the GTE always starts on electric drive
so it doesn't wake the neighbors and it
can glide meaning the engine uncouples
from the transmission so that the car
can coach down the highway for example
without using any electricity
VW rates average fuel consumption at 1.8
liters for 100 kilometers that figures
in the distance covered on electric
drive with both power trains working
together the GTE accelerates from 0 to
100 and 7.4 seconds reaching a maximum
speed of 225 kilometers per hour
[Music]
the plug-in hybrid passant requires deep
pockets the sedan was for forty four
thousand two hundred fifty euros in
germany the station wagon for a thousand
more that puts it at the upper end of
the Passat range alongside the most
powerful fully equipped versions the
interior makes no compromises everything
we've come to expect of a Passat
[Music]
final points out that the GTE ranges
forty to fifty kilometers on a fully
charged battery it may not sound like
much but it's more than enough for
eighty percent of daily driving a normal
European 220 volt household outlet fully
recharges the battery in about four
hours
according to VW the conventional
gasoline engine combined with electric
drive makes for a total range of some
1,100 kilometers so it's no disaster if
you can't find the time to recharge now
and then but the straightforward
charging process quickly becomes a habit
and takes optimal advantage of the
electric drive technology
[Music]
coming up Rhino says the Passat GTE
means the future is now he can use it to
commute to work on electric drive only
but he still has to halt to power trains
around the gasoline engine and the
electric motor and it comes at a price
even so this plug-in Hybrid says I'm
moving toward the future